So to implement the shared element
transition we need to designate which
views are shared.
We do this by setting the same
transitionName attribute
on the views in both activities.
I tend to use a string resource
to make sure they match exactly.
Next, when we launch the activity,
we need to use a variant of the
ActivityOptions.makeSceneTransitionAnim-
ation API, that let's us
specify the shared elements.
We pass this API the View and the
TransitionName so that it can look for
its counterpart in the launch activity.
They're a variants of this API for
specifying a single shared
element like this or
ways to specify many shared elements, if
you want multiple things to transition.
Note that, interestingly,
the TransitionName field is a string,
rather than, perhaps,
identifying a view by ID.
This is because shared element
transitions don't just work between
screens within your own app.
You can publish the transition
names you support and
have shared element transitions
between different applications.
Pretty rad.
So that's enough to create
a shared element transition.
Not too much effort for
quite an impressive effect.
You may be wondering how the system
knew to animate the size and
position in our example.
Well, by default,
shared element transitions use
a built-in transition called Move.
This is what it looks like.
The changeBounds transition does a lot
of the heavy lifting and moves and
resizes elements between states.
The remaining transitions help with
images to change the transformatio and
clip applied to them.
If you want to customize the animations
used, then we can create our own
transitions, and set them in a similar
way to the activity content transitions.
Here's how you'd set a custom
transition via XML and via code.